a solar eclipse happens when the moon
shadow falls somewhere on the surface of
Earth and a lunar eclipse is the
opposite when the Earth's shadow falls
on the moon the two sections of the
shadow the dark Umbra and the partially
shaded penumbra their placement
determines which type of Eclipse we can
see from Earth but not all eclipses are
made equal the most spectacular the one
for your bucket list is a total eclipse
of the Sun a total solar eclipse begins
as a partial eclipse you'll notice trees
projecting the crescent Sun and shadows
becoming sharper than normal the
landscape darkens to a blueish gray and
you'll start to feel the temperature
drop from the west the moon shadow
rushes towards you like a Silent Storm
look up and you'll see the last sliver
of the sun's sparkling like a diamond
ring before it's broken into a string of
beads by the moon's rough terrain now
you can see the pearly glow of the sun's
corona and the pink and red light from
the hydrogen gas of the chromis fear
together these make up the sun's outer
atmosphere and a total solar eclipse is
the only occasion you have to lay eyes
on it this is totality and if you get a
chance to see it you should the moon
orbits earth every twenty nine and a
half days but we don't get eclipses
every month that's because the moon's
orbit isn't in line with Earth's orbit
it's tilted about five degrees that
doesn't seem like much but keep in mind
that the scale of the model we're
showing to you is way off if the Earth
and Moon are this size the distance
between them should be around 10 feet at
this distance five degrees is enough to
keep the moon shadow off of Earth and
the Earth's shadow off the moon most
months so why do we ever get eclipses
because there are two points where the
moon's orbit crosses the sun's plane
called notes and as the earth moves
along its annual orbit those points line
up with the Sun about twice a year as
the moon passes between the Sun and
Earth at that time we get a solar
eclipse and when it's behind Earth at
that time we get a lunar eclipse there
are a ton of orbital quirks that make
predicting eclipses really complicated
but in general we'll have a few solar
and
lunar eclipses of some sort every year
but you're more likely to see a total
lunar eclipse in your lifetime than a
total solar one the totality of a lunar
eclipse can last well over an hour and
it's viewable for anyone on the night
side of Earth the moon often turns red
during a total lunar eclipse because our
planet's atmosphere scatters the bluer
wavelengths of light while the longer
redder wavelengths pass through or to
put it another way a total lunar eclipse
projects all of the world's sunsets and
sunrises onto the moon total solar
eclipses seem much more rare because
totality lasts just a few minutes
and although earth gets a total solar
eclipse every 18 months on average each
one is only viewable by less than half a
percent of Earth's surface eclipse
chasers travel all over the world to put
themselves in the path of that shadow in
a total solar eclipse the moon precisely
covers the Sun from the vantage point of
some place on earth this is possible
because by coincidence the Sun and the
moon appear to be about the same size in
our sky while the Sun is 400 times
bigger than the moon it's also about 400
times farther away but this alignment
isn't constant the moon has an
elliptical orbit it's size varies about
12% throughout the month when it's
closer to us we can get total solar
eclipses but less than 30% of solar
eclipses are totaled more often we get
partial eclipses where the alignment is
a bit off or annular eclipses where the
moon is too far away to fully block the
Sun leaving a ring of sunlight around
the moon in the far future
earth will only get annular and partial
solar eclipses because our Moon is
moving further away we know that because
Buzz Aldrin and Neil Armstrong left
mirrors on the moon in 1969 astronomers
bounce lasers off those mirrors to
measure the moon's distance and that's
how they found out that the moon is
moving away from Earth by more than
three centimeters per year so in a
billion years or so whatever creatures
live here will witness Earth's very last
total solar eclipse
[Music]
we can say on the radio on the screen
fantastic total solar eclipse taken from
the pictures about the clouds
this is just fantastic a lot of early
civilizations feared eclipses they were
seen as an attack on the Sun or moon by
the forces of darkness but now that we
understand our place in space eclipses
are an occasion for awe and for
gratitude all over the galaxy rocks are
casting shadows on other rocks but only
here as far as we know is there someone
to notice them
[Music]